Thanks for having me here.
Yeah.
So I'm,
uh,
I'm based in the Cambridge office,
which is like a 100 meters that way.
Um,
and we do a lot of stuff with a deep
learning.
We've got a large group in Google brain
and other related fields.
So hopefully that's interesting to some
of you at some point.
So I'm going to talk for about 20
minutes or so.
Um,
this sort of issues and image
classification theme.
Let me hand it over to my excellent
colleagues hunching king who's going to
go through an entirely different subject
in a using tensorflow debugger and eager
mode to make work intensive flow easier.
Maybe that will be good.
Okay.
Um,
so let's,
let's take a step back.
So have you guys seen happy graphs like
this before?
Go ahead and smile and nod if you've
seen stuff like this.
Yeah.
Okay.
So this is a happy graph on image,
net based image classification.
So image net is a data set of a million
some odd images for this challenge.
There were a thousand classes,
um,
and uh,
in 2011 back in the dark ages when
nobody knew how to do anything,
the state of the art was something like
25 percent error rate on this stuff.
And in the last call it six,
seven years,
the reduction in error rate has been
kind of astounding to the point where
it's now been talked about so much.
It's like no longer even surprising and
everyone's like,
yeah,
we've see this,
um,
human error rate is somewhere between
five and 10 percent on,
on,
on this task.
So the contemporary results of,
you know,
two point two or whatever it is,
percent error rate or really kind of
astonishing.
Um,
and you can look at a graph like this
and make reasonable claims that well,
machines we're using deep learning are
better than humans that impinged
classification on this task.
That's kind of weird and kind of
amazing.
And maybe we can declare victory and
fill audiences full of people clamoring
to learn about deep learning.
That's cool.
Okay.
So,
um,
I'm going to talk not about image data
itself,
but about a slightly different image
data set.
Basically people were like,
okay,
obviously image net is too easy.
Let's make a larger,
more interesting data set.
So open images was released I think a
year or two ago.
It's got about 9 million as opposed to 1
million images.
The base data set has 6,000
labels as opposed to 1000 labels.
This ultra multi label.
So you get,
you know,
if there's a person holding a rugby
ball,
you get both person and rugby ball and
the Dataset.
It's got all kinds of classes including
stairs here,
which are lovely,
lovely illustrated.
And you can find this on get hub.
It's a nice data set to play around
with.
So uh,
some colleagues and I did some work of
saying,
okay,
what happens if we apply just a straight
up inception based model,
um,
to this data we traded up.
And then we'd look at some how would
classify as some that we found on the
web.
So here's one such image,
a image that we found on the web.
All the images here are creative
comments and stuff like that.
So it's,
it's okay for us to look at these and
when we apply an image based,
a,
a image,
nobody kind of model to this
classifications we get back or kind of
what I personally would expect.
I'm seeing things like bride dress
ceremony,
woman wedding,
all things that as an American in this
country at this time I'm thinking or
make make sense for this image.
Cool.
Maybe we did solve it.
Image classification.
So,
um,
then we had played it to another image.
Also have a bride and a,
the model that we had trained up on this
open source image data set returned the
following classifications,
clothing event,
costume red and performance art.
I'm no mention of bride,
also,
no mention of person Nis regardless of
gender.
Um,
so in a sense this,
this model is sort of like missed the
fact that there's a human in the picture
which is maybe not awesome and not
really what I would think of as great
success if we're claiming that image
classification is solved.
Um,
okay.
So what's going on here?
Um,
I'm going to argue a little bit that
what's going on is,
is based in,
to some degree on the idea of
stereotypes and uh,
if you're,
if you have your laptop open,
I'd like you to close your laptop for a
second.
This is the interactive portion where
you can interact by closing your laptop
and,
um,
I'd like you to find somebody sitting
next to you and exercise your human
conversation skills for about one minute
to come up with a definition between the
two of you have,
what is a stereotype keeping in mind
that we're in sort of a statistical
setting.
Okay?
So have a quick one minute conversation
with the person sitting next to you.
If there's no one sitting next to you,
you may move.
Ready,
set,
go.
Three,
two,
one.
And thank you for having that
interesting conversation that easily
could have lasted for much more than one
minute,
but such is life.
Let's hear from one or two folks who had
something that they came up with.
It was interesting.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
Your name is at that?
Yeah.
Okay.
What did you
based?
Okay,
so you saying that a stereotype is a
generalization that you find from a
large group of people and you apply it
to more people.
Okay,
interesting.
I'm certainly agree with large parts of
that.
Yeah,
go ahead.
That's based on probability and
experience with the human goal.
For you,
would it be free?
Okay.
So,
so here the claimant said it's a label
that's based on experience from within
your training set.
Yep.
Super interesting.
And I'm the probability of label based
on what's,
what's your training say?
Cool.
Maybe one more.
Oh yeah,
got it.
You're making a prediction based upon to
be coordinated and integrated.
Okay.
So the claim here,
that stereotype has something to do with
unrelated features that happened to be
correlated.
I think that's interesting.
Let me see if I can.
This was not a plant.
I'm sorry,
your name was
awesome.
Constantine.
Constantine is not a plant.
Um,
but I do want to look at this a little
bit more in detail.
So here's a,
here's a Dataset that I'm going to claim
is,
is based on running data.
Um,
so,
uh,
in the early mornings I pretend that I'm
an athlete and go for a run.
Um,
and uh,
this is a dataset that sort of based on
risk that someone might not finish a
race that they enter in a.
So we've got high risk.
People are,
you know,
are in yellow and lower risk.
People are in red.
I'm going to walk,
get this data.
It's got a couple of dimensions.
I might fit a linear classifier.
It's not quite perfect if I look a
little more closely,
if I've actually got some more
information here I've done just to have
x and y also had this sort of color have
outline.
So I might have a rule that if this data
point has a blue outline,
I'm going to predict low risk.
Otherwise I'm going to predict high
risk.
Fair enough.
Um,
now the big reveal,
you'll never guess what,
um,
the,
uh,
the outline feature is based on shoe
type.
The other x and y are based on how long
the races and sort of what a person's
weekly training volume is.
But whether you're foolish enough to buy
expensive running shoes because you
think they're going to make you faster
or whatever,
um,
this is what's in the data.
And in
traditional machine learning,
supervised machine learning,
we might say,
well,
wait a minute,
I'm not sure that shoe type is going to
be actually predictive.
On the other hand,
it's in her training data and it does
seem to be awfully predictive on this
data set.
We have a really simple model is highly
regularized.
It still gives you know,
perfect or near perfect accuracy.
Maybe it's fine.
And
the only way we can find out if it's
not,
I would argue is by gathering some more
data and I'll point out that this data
set has been diabolically constructed so
that there are some points in the space
that are not particularly well
represented.
And you can maybe tell yourself a story
about maybe this data was collected
after some corporate five k or something
like that.
Um,
so if we go out and collect some more
data,
maybe we find that actually there's
people wearing all kinds of shoes on
both sides of,
of our imaginary classifier.
But that this shoe type feature is
really not predictive at all and this
gets back to Constantine's point that
perhaps,
uh,
relying on features that are strongly
correlated but not necessarily causal,
may be a point at which we're thinking
about a stereotype in some way.
Um,
so obviously given this data and what we
know now,
I would probably go back and suggest to
linear classifier based on these,
these features of length of race and
weekly training volumes as potentially a
better model to how does this happen?
What's,
what's,
what's the issue here that said play.
I'm one of the issues that's at play is
that in supervised machine learning,
we often make the assumption that our
training distribution and our test
distribution are identical.
Right?
And we make this assumption for really
good reason,
which is that if we make that
assumption,
then we can pretend that there's no
difference between correlation and
causation.
And we can use all of our features,
whether they're what Constantine would
call meaningful or causal or not.
Um,
we can throw them in there and so long
as they're testing training
distributions are the same.
We're probably okay to within some some
degree,
but in the real world we don't just
apply models to a training or test set.
We also use them to make predictions
that may influence the world in some
way.
And there I think that the right sort of
phrase to use isn't so much tests set.
It's more inference time performance.
Okay.
Because at,
at inference time,
when we're going and applying our model
to some new instance in the world,
we may not actually know what they let
the true label is ever or things like
that,
but we still care very much about having
good performance and making sure that
our,
uh,
test that our training set matches our
inference distribution to some degree
is,
is like super critical.
Um,
so let's go back to open images and what
was happening there.
Um,
you'll recall that it did quite badly
on,
at least anecdotally on that image of a
bride who appeared to be from India.
Um,
if we look at the Geo diversity of open
images,
this is something where we did our best
to sort of track down the geolocation
of,
of each of the images in the open image
data set.
Uh,
what we found was that an overwhelming
proportion of the data in open images,
uh,
was from North America and six countries
in Europe,
um,
vanishingly small amounts of that data
were from countries such as India or
China or other places where I've heard
there's actually a large number of
people.
So this is clearly not representative in
a meaningful way of sort of the global
diversity of the world.
How does this happen?
It's not like the researchers who put
the open images dataset.
We're in any way on all intention.
They were working really hard to put
together what they believe was a more
representative data set than the image
net.
Um,
at the very least,
they don't have 100 categories of dogs
in this one.
Um,
so what happens?
Well,
you could make an argument that there's
some strong correlation with the
distribution of open images with the
distribution of countries with high,
low,
high bandwidth,
low cost,
Internet access.
Um,
it's not a perfect correlation,
but it's,
it's pretty close.
Um,
and that if we're doing a,
if one might do things like base an
image classifier on data drawn from a
distribution of areas that have high
bandwidth,
low cost Internet access,
um,
that may induce differences between the
trading distribution and the inference
time distribution.
So none of this is like something you
wouldn't figure out without it if you
sat down for five minutes.
Right?
This is all like super basic statistics.
It is in fact stuff that's this just six
people have been sort of railing at the
machine learning community at for the
last several decades.
Um,
but as machine learning models become
sort of more ubiquitous in everyday
life,
I think that paying attention to these
kinds of issues becomes ever more
important.
Uh,
so let's go back to,
to what is a stereotype and I think I
agree with Constantine's,
um,
idea.
And I'm going to add one more tweak to
it.
So I'm going to say that a stereotype is
a statistical confounder.
I think Susan Constantine's language
almost exactly a that has a societal
basis.
So when I think about issues of
fairness,
if it's the case that,
um,
you know,
rainy weather is correlated with people
using umbrellas,
like,
yes,
that's a confounder.
The umbrellas did not cause the rain.
Um,
but I'm not as worried as a individual
human about the societal impact of
models that are based on that module.
I'm sure you could imagine some crazies,
scary scenario where that was the case,
but in general,
I don't think that that's an issue,
but when we think of things like
internet connectivity or other societal
factors,
I think that paying attention to
questions of do we have confounders in
our data,
are they being picked up by our models?
Um,
is,
is incredibly important.
So,
um,
if you take away nothing else from this
short talk,
I hope that you take away a caution to
be aware of differences between your
training and inference asked the
question,
uh,
because statistically this is not a
particularly difficult thing to uncover
if you take the time to look in a world
of kaggle competitions and people trying
to get high marks on deep learning
classes and things like that.
I think it's all too easy for us to just
take datasets as given not thinking
about them too much and just try and get
our accuracy from 99 point one to 99
point two.
And as someone who's interested in
people coming out of programs like this
being ready to do work in the real world
at a,
I would caution that,
um,
we can't only be training ourselves to
do that.
So with that,
I'm going to leave you with a set of
additional resources around machine
learning fairness.
These are super hot off the presses in
the sense that this particular little
website was launched at I think 8:30
this morning,
something like that.
So you've got it first.
Um,
mit leading the way,
I'm in on this page.
Uh,
there are in,
yeah,
you can open your laptops again now.
Um,
uh,
there are a number of papers that go
through this sort of like a greatest
hits of the machine learning fairness
literature from the last couple of
years.
Um,
really interesting papers.
I don't think any of them are like the
one final solution to machine learning
fairness issues,
but they're super interesting reads that
I think help sort of paint the space and
the landscape really usefully.
There are also a couple of interesting
exercises there,
um,
that,
uh,
you can access by a colab.
Um,
and uh,
if you're interested in this space,
there things that you can play with a,
I think they include one on adversarial
d biasing where I'm,
because you guys all love deep learning.
Um,
you can use a network to try and become
unbiased by,
uh,
making sure that by having an extra
output head that predicts a
characteristic that you wish to be
unbiased on and then panelizing that
model if it's good at predicting that,
that characteristic.
Uh,
and so this is trying to adversarially
make sure that our internal
representation in a deep network is not
picking up a unwanted correlations
around one biases.
So I hope that that's interesting.
Um,
and,
uh,
I'll be around afterwards to take
questions,
but at this point I'd like to make sure
that sunshine has plenty of time.
So thank you very much.